In the name of the Father and of the Son and of the Holy Spirit, Amen.
The reading from the Sinaxadion from May 15th, on which we commemorate our righteous
Father, Pacomios the Great.
On the 15th of the month we celebrate the memory of our venerable Father, Pacomios the Great.
Our blessed Father Pacomios was born of pagan parents in Upper Egypt and about 292.
From childhood he felt a lively repulsion for idol worship and showed a natural inclination
towards good.
Forced into the army during Maximinus Deas campaign against Licinius in 312, he was
moved by the charitable attitude of the Christians of Thebes towards the conscripts who were being
dragged without consideration to the garrison as prisoners.
Despite without delay, he was baptized in the village of Sinacet.
And on the following night saw a dew descending from heaven and spread over his head, then condensed
in his right hand and became a honey that flowed down all over the ground.
He immediately began to live the ascetic life, being guided only by his conscience, serving
the local people, especially during an outbreak of plague.
After three years, disturbed by the frequent visits of Lafalk and animated dense forth by
a violent love for God alone, he became the disciple of a holy elder, a harsh and austere
man who lived in solitude outside the village, Saint Palamon.
After having severely tested him, Palamon clothed him in the monastic habit and taught
him to keep the vigils as he himself did.
Half the night and sometimes all night through, reciting passages from scripture to fast all
day till nightfall in summer, and only to eat one day in two or three in winter, without
ever taking oil, wine or cooked food.
Her liturgical office consisted during the night of fifty groups of Psalms, concluding
with a prayer and sixty during the day, without counting the constant recollection of God,
that they held in their hearts and spirits, according to the Apostles' recommendation,
in 1 Thessalonians 5-17.
To provide for their needs and especially for those of the poor, they plated articles from
wire, linen or pine fiber, even working at night while reciting the word of God in order
to combat sleep.
If in spite of the manual work, sleep over King them, they got up and carried sand in baskets
from one part of the desert to another.
One Easter day Pacomius poured a little oil on the crushed salt that was their staple diet.
Amon struck himself on the face and burst into tears, saying, My Lord is crucified, and
I use oil.
Pacomius not only endured the Elder's rigorous discipline with a good will, but applied
himself beyond all else to keeping his heart pure by strict vigilance over his thoughts,
employing all the resources of his spirit and learning the word of God by heart in order
to make it his own.
He would go off into the desert to pray or stand the whole night among the graves, stretching
his hands heavy words as though crucified, and sweating so much that the ground beneath
his feet became muddy.
During his nocturnal prayers, the demons sat on him and attacked him openly, but the man
of God covered them with confusion, praising God, and mocking their futile artifices.
When their attacks became more vehement, he mortified his body even more and asked God to
deprive him of sleep until he had achieved a definitive victory.
His prayer was heard and he acquired from then on such favor with God that his body could
already delight in some small measure in the incorruptibility promised to the elect.
He could tread on serpents and scorpions without danger and could cross the Nile among the
crocodiles.
After four years of striving, the vision of the heavenly dew came again, but he waited
a further three years before withdrawing to the solitude of the desert.
When he arrived in a place called Tabanisi on the northeast bank of the Nile, he heard a
voice from heaven telling him to stay there and found a monastery.
Having obtained Pallamon's agreement just before his death, Pacomios settled there and gave
himself to strict askees in solitude until his eldest brother John came to join him.
Having all things in common, they lived in great renunciation and gave the fruit of their
labor away to the poor, keeping only what was strictly necessary for life.
Two loaves and a little salt every day.
At the end of their vigil, they took a short rest, sitting without leaning against the wall.
During the day they exposed themselves to the intense heat of the sun, keeping the passion
of our Savior Jesus Christ and the trials of the martyrs in mind.
One day an angel of God appeared to Pacomios while he was keeping vigil and said to him three
times, Pacomios, it is the will of God that you serve the human race, to reconcile
them with him.
From then on men from the nearby villages gathered around him to live the hermit life together,
each of them lived alone as he desired and each did his part for the material needs of
the community.
Pacomios put himself humbly at their service, prepared the food that they desired, received
the guests and tended the brethren when they were sick.
Although he contented himself with bread and salt at all times, these rough men, however,
showed him no respect.
They despised his humility and even mocked him.
The men of God possessed his soul in patience for five years, until the day when, after having
received the command from God during a night of prayer, he imposed a rule of common life
on them and drove away with authority those who would not conform.
New candidates for monastic life presented themselves.
Pacomios, after having strictly tested them, directed them to live according to the scriptures,
having all in common in perfect equality, in imitation of the apostolic community.
Placing himself at their service as formerly, he taught them to carry their cross and follow
Christ, and to have no care but that of recalling the Lord's words in their spirits.
It is said that an angel dressed as a monk showed him the model of their habit, and gave
him a tablet on which the rule of the community was written.
It prescribed that food and drink be given to each according to his constitution and work,
without holding back those who wish to practice greater esquices.
They had to live in separate cells grouped in houses according to their affinity or occupation,
but came together three times a day to address to God twelve groups of Psalms and prayer.
When Pacomios objected that this did not add up to many prayers, the angel replied, all that
I prescribe is to ensure that even the little ones can observe the rule without discouragement.
As for the perfect, they have no need of laws, because in their cells they consecrate their
whole lives to the contemplation of God.
When the number of brethren reached a hundred, Pacomios built them a church in the monastery,
and on Sundays asked a priest from the village to come and celebrate the divine liturgy, as
he refused to allow any of his monks to be ordained priest from fear that Vanglory and
jealousy would come and shatter their harmony.
Shortly after Saint Athanasios' consecration as Archbishop of Alexandria, he visited
the monastery of Tabernisi in 329, but Pacomios, having learned that he wished to ordain
him priest, hid until the prelate had left.
The community that he called the Quinoña, grew a pace.
Pacomios appointed brethren, confirmed in virtue to assist him, one as administrator of their
material needs, with a helper, others had the charge of looking after the sick, the reception
of guests, or of the selling outside of the products made by the monastery.
Three times a week Saint Pacomios called the community together, and himself instructed
the brethren, interpreting the scriptures and, on the two fast days, the heads of the houses
in their turn, gave a catacasus for their respective monks.
Pacomios' sister, Maria, having also come to join him, the saint had a monastery built
in the village, where many sisters came together to live a life like that of the monks, guided
by an austere and wise elder called Peter.
The saint received the candidates who presented themselves with circumspection, and only accepted
a small number of those who had earlier been living a sinful life, or were of recalcitrant
character, for fear they would lead the other brethren astray.
But as for those among them whom he accepted, he strove with them day and night to remove
them from bondage to the passions.
When he found unmanageable monks he attempted to set them right, and prayed earnestly for
them, adding to his fasts, vigils, and mortifications, so that they would repent and learn the
mystery of the monastic life, and the peace that one finds in obedience.
But if they persisted in their contrarianess, he sent them away from the community, so as
not to hinder the brethren's growth in the fear of God.
One year he sent away more than a hundred monks of the three hundred who made up the community.
With his gift of insight Saint Pacomios perceived the faults and perverse thoughts of the
brethren, and knew how to heal them before they had committed sin.
Although he healed the sick and delivered the possessed, both among the brethren, and
the layful who crowded around the monastery, he submitted everything to the will of God
and was never cast down when the Lord did not hear his prayer.
He taught that the spiritual healing of souls which, turning from error or negligence, come
to the knowledge of the true God and repent, is greater than the healing of the body.
He never asked for visions of God as they could be a way of delusion and said, if you see
a man, pure and humble, that is a great vision.
For what is greater than such a vision to see the invisible God in a visible man, the temple
of God?
Even when he was laid low by sickness, the blessed man refused to be served or given any sort
of relief.
He accepted one remedy and one alone, the name of the Lord, and taught the sick by his example
to endure their ills with patience and thanksgiving in order to receive a double crown of esquices
and of patience under trials.
When the brethren were sick, he was infallibly able to detect those that were roused by
demons or by their passions and taught them to overcome them with firm resolution of soul.
But when it was a matter of real physical weakness, he went himself to serve the sick and did
not hesitate to give meat to certain of them, despite the monastic practice.
The number of brethren growing unceasingly, Pacomios, after a further vision, founded
another monastery at Fobo, a little downstream on the Nile, about two miles from Tabanisi.
He had had built very large and organized it in the same way as Tabanisi.
When Fobo had been populated, the superior of a monastery called Genoboschion, the goose
pasture, now Seneset, asked the saint to place this community under his jurisdiction, with
the same rule of life.
Pacomios went there with several of the brethren, whom he left to instruct the monks in the
discipline of the Kino Nia.
He did the same thing for the monastery of Moncosis, Thmusons, and then after a further vision
founded a new monastery at Se.
At the request of the Bishop of Panopolis, Smin, he founded yet another in that region, working
himself with brethren to raise the buildings.
Shortly afterwards, a well-known man called Petronios offered the monastery that he had
founded at Thbu, in the Diospolis region.
St. Pacomios placed a certain Apologios at the head of the monastery and made Petronios the
superior of another foundation, Smin, near Panopolis.
Finally, after one more vision, he founded a very large monastery at Phonum, far away to
the south of the desert of Sne.
This huge congregation of nine men's monasteries and two for women comprised 3,000 monks during
the lifetime of St. Pacomios, and later up to 7,000.
They all lived in harmony and faithfulness to the laws instituted by the man of God.
There was among them no care for worldly affairs, and they were constantly transported to heaven
by their angelic way of life.
The saint often visited one or the other to instruct the monks in the word of God, setting
right the deficiencies and encouraging the brethren to persevere in their striving.
He was normally resident in the monastery of Fobo where he lived as a simple monk, a member
of a house, and subject to common discipline.
For immovably established on the rock of humility, he had never thought of himself as the head
or father of the monks but as their servant.
In Tabernisi, one day, he sat down to work and led himself be taught by a slip of a monk
who scolded him for not doing the work properly.
The steward of the great monastery of Fobo was charged with supervising the material administration
of the Kino Nia.
He collected the objects made in the monastery and saw to all their needs.
Twice a year the brethren met together at Fobo to celebrate the feast of Easter altogether
and in the month of August after the harvest.
The steward submitted their accounts to him and he proceeded with the appointment to new offices.
When Pecomios did not have the time to visit one of the monasteries, he sent his most beloved
disciple Theodore or wrote a letter to the steward in a secret language that only the
recipient could understand.
He was always sad and grave of face as God had given him to see the eternal torment reserved
for sinners and for monks unworthy of their calling.
And this is why every time that he spoke in public, he admonished his disciples on the
judgment to come.
One day a negligent monk died.
The saint ordered with authority that no funeral be solemnized nor the divine liturgy
be celebrated in his memory and that his clothing be burned, leaving all the brethren in dread
as a way of reforming them.
During a famine the man of God fasted constantly and said, I shall not eat either if my brothers
who are hungry have no bread to eat.
Thus applying the apostles' words, whether one member suffer, all the members suffer
with it.
Saint Pecomios' reputation having spread throughout Egypt, it came about that there were some who
cast out on his gift of insight and his revelations.
Summoned to Lactopolis in 345 before an assembly of bishops who questioned him on the subject,
Pecomios replied that the Lord did not constantly give him such grace of prescience and discernment
of hearts, but only when he willed it to the edification of the Kenonia and the salvation
of souls, and to the measure of his own submission to the will of God.
He was declared innocent, giving thanks to God and concerning this trial and the exile
of Saint Athanasios declared, we must endure all sorts of trials because they do no harm
to us.
Around Easter 346 an epidemic of plague broke out in the Kenonia and killed more than a hundred
of the most eminent brothers.
The saint caught it in his turn, but refused any special treatment, although his body was
greatly weakened his eyes were full of flame.
He spent the first days of great week in praying the Lord that the unity of the Kenonia
would not be broken after his death.
Then calling the brethren together, he took them as witnesses that during his life he had
never concealed anything and had lived as one of them, behaving to all as a servant and
a nurse who tends her children.
He added that the rules and traditions that he had instituted for them under the Lord's
inspiration were the only way of finding rest of soul and eternal salvation.
Around Pentecost he designated Petronios who had himself also caught the illness to be
his successor, and then ordered the brethren to cease their weeping as the Lord had commanded
him to go and join the abode of the fathers.
He ordered Theodore with great severity to bury his body in a secret place so that no veneration
be given it and exhorted him to care for his negligent brethren.
He gave his apostolic soul into God's hands on the 9th of May in 346 at the age of 54.
At that moment the area was shaken by an earthquake, a heavenly fragrance was released and many
elders saw hosts of angels escorting the saint's soul to the place of his rest.
In Saint Anthony, the great herd in his distant desert of Saint Pekomios' death, he praised
him as a new apostle and gave great eulogies on the senabitic life of which he was the founder.
Answering those who said that he himself had achieved greater glory in the aromatic life,
he replied that it was out of necessity that he had to embrace the solitary life because
there was then no synobium, and he added, in the kingdom of heaven, we shall see one another,
we shall see all the fathers and above all, we shall see our master and our God, Jesus Christ.
After the death of Saint Pekomios, Petronios governed the Kenonia only a few days before himself
giving his soul into God's keeping. Abba Orciusius was then designated to watch over the monks
respect for the traditions, and to ensure following Pekomios' example, the ministry of the word.
But after the rebellion by Apoloneus, the superior of the monastery of Moncossus,
Orciusius resigned and put Theodor in his place as superior. After the death of Saint Pekomios' first
disciples, the monasteries of the Kenonia grew enormously, both in numbers and in material goods,
but this flowering was short-lived, and after having become victims of decadence,
the monks were carried off by the barbarian invaders.
The institutions, written rules, and above all the spirit of synobidicism, of which Saint Pekomios
was the founder, were nevertheless bequeathed to the church, as the perfect way of imitating
the apostolic community, and as a latter raised towards the kingdom of heaven,
through the prayers of our Holy Fathers, O Lord Jesus Christ, our God,
of mercy on us, and save us.